chyna third century BC a story is told
of a merchant trying to sell a spear and
a shield when a customer asks how good a
spear is the merchant tells him that his
spear could shears any shield the
customer then asks how good the
merchants shield is and he responds that
it can defend from all spear attacks the
customer then asks one final question
what would happen if he were to take the
merchant spear and strike the shield the
merchant had no answer
this story originated the Chinese word
for contradiction maude win literally
translated spear shield so what does
happen when an unstoppable force meets
an immovable object let's find out
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory show where brains
always defeat wrong the show where
sometimes maybe brains can in theory be
preferable to strength you know one of
the biggest challenges with
entertainment it constantly has to
one-up itself in order to stay new fresh
and exciting the first time the matrix
showed the world bullet time no one had
ever seen anything like it but nowadays
it's all old hats that first big team up
in the Avengers iconic cinema but then
Marvel couldn't just do it again it
already had been done it had to evolve
to stay fresh so they did more heroes
than they had him fight each other and
then again an infinity war they one-up
themselves yet again by mixing the
powers in really cool ways you can't
just watch people in capes kick and
punch each other anymore the standard
has been raised for audiences time and
time again the reason I bring this up is
because escalation is hard at a certain
point you hit a ceiling and it's really
hard to go backwards if the fate of the
world is on the line for a given movie
well it's hard to go back to stories
where the fate of the city is on the
line and after the fate of the world
where do you go the fate of the galaxy
then you're just stuck quite honestly
the same holds true for superheroes and
their powers Superman's biggest weakness
as a character it isn't kryptonite it's
that he's too strong so today I wanted a
bit too of superhero fiction's most
escalated creations against each other
to see which one comes out on top the a
movable object or the unstoppable force
in our first corner at 5 foot 9 weighing
154 pounds we have the guy whose
greatest curse is that he wins every
plate with a single punch a character
whose very existence is meant to parity
overpowered anime super heroes and the
guy who shows us just how important it
is to never skip leg day ladies and
gentlemen I'm of course talking about a
Baldy who is far from basic one punch
man
Saitama how strong is Saitama insanely
strong mechanical beings mutated
warriors monsters walls building swords
meteors with a single punch Saitama is
able to bring each and every one down
his only weakness
boredom in the second corner it's our
movable object the strongest material in
all the Marvel film averse the alien
metal behind Captain America's
impenetrable shield and black panther
suit able to protect our favorite heroes
from being nice shot or dismembered but
watch out for those snaps it's the most
indestructible metal that Marvel has the
rights to put up on screen vibranium
Kisai and Logan Paul eat your hearts out
this is the biggest fight on YouTube and
I'm not even gonna make it pay ten bucks
for it
so let's get ready to figure out who
wins the battle between vibranium
defensive abilities and saitama's
offensive power we first need to figure
out just how strong each one truly is so
let's start with vibranium what makes
this intergalactic metal so perfect for
a match like this isn't how strong or
durable it is but because it has the
ability to absorb kinetic energy for
those of you unfamiliar in physics
kinetic energy is basically movement
energy all moving things have kinetic
energy which means that when Saitama
goes to punch it the vibranium should be
able to absorb most if not all of the
force of saitama's punch storing that
impact within the bonds of the material
calculating the kinetic energy of an
object is pretty easy all it is is
one-half mass times velocity squared so
is it possible to measure the limits of
how much kinetic energy a given amount
of vibranium can handle well we see
multiple examples throughout the Marvel
film verse of vibranium durability in
Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain America uses his vibranium
shield to easily deflect bullets in
black panther we see vibranium deflect
multiple machine-gun bullets it reflects
energy blasts from Iron Man and Civil
War and can cushion fall spot without
question the greatest feat of vibranium
strength we see in the movies happens in
the Avengers when Captain America uses
his shield to repel Thor's hammer
Mjolnir
which is some serious power because as
stated in Thor Jana forged in the heart
of a dying star and star matter is
massive according to Neil deGrasse Tyson
on Twitter quote Neil deGrasse Tyson if
Thor's hammer is made of neutron star
matter as implied by legend that it
weighs as much as a herd of 300 billion
elephants that's clearly Neil deGrasse
Tyson nailed it now I can already hear
the angry internet commenters typing
furiously that Odin said Thor's hammer
was forged in a dying star not from a
dying star and yeah in the comics Thor's
hammer isn't constructed from star
matter but instead out of an enchanted
metal called Aroo however in the Marvel
film verse it all might just be one in
the same you see this is how Thor
describes the material his hammer is
made out of in thor ragnarok he was made
from this special message from the
hospital dying star it was made from
this special metal from the heart of a
star and then again in Avengers infinity
war we see the construction of Thor's
replacement hammer axe Stormbreaker and
it seems like the heat of the star is
used more to heat this mystery metal
rather than fill the mold how do we make
it break in the heart of a dying star we
even know what type of star it is if it
is forged harness is the blazing power
of a neutron star
long story short at best guru and
neutron star material in the movies are
one in the same and at worst marvel
universe just can't keep it all straight
regardless / National Geographic a
single sugar cube of a neutron star has
a mass of 100 million tons so even if
Thor's hammer isn't made of star
material well it's still gonna give us
one massive estimate for how much
kinetic energy that hammer generates and
how much vibranium can actually
withstand so the mass of an object is
equal to its density times its volume
the density of a neutron star is on
average approximately 10 to the 17th
kilograms per cubic meter and per the
one to one Marvel licensed replica the
dimensions of Thor's hammer are eight
and a half inches in height five and a
half inches in width and five and a half
inches in length which makes the volume
of the hammer to be 257 point one two
five cubic inches or point zero zero
four two one three five two three eight
three one cubic meters which means that
the mass of Thor's hammer is
- 10 to the 17th times point zero zero
for all that mass or 421 trillion three
hundred and fifty two billion three
hundred and eighty three million one
hundred thousand kilograms or if you're
in America nine hundred and twenty eight
trillion nine hundred and twenty-two
billion nine hundred ninety five million
five hundred and fifty two thousand one
hundred fifty one pounds holy Odin that
is a ton of weights it's actually a lot
more than a ton of weight that is
seventy-one thousand times the weight of
the Great Pyramid at Giza
eight thousand times the weight of the
entire Great Wall of China which is
assumed to be the heaviest man-made
structure in the world at one hundred
and sixteen billion pounds but we can't
actually confirm that since you know
can't really pick up the thing and throw
it onto a scale so let's say
hypothetically speaking that Thor can
wield is hammer at least as fast as an
ace pitcher 100 miles per hour or forty
five meters per second that would mean
that the energy required to deflect
Thor's hammer is 426 quadrillion 619
trillion two hundred and eighty seven
billion eight hundred and eighty eight
million seven hundred fifty thousand
joules to put that into context that is
more than twice as much energy as the
largest nuclear weapon ever tested on
planet Earth
nothing ever devised on planet earth
could ever take vibranium down but then
what about something that was devised in
anime one punch man has done a lot of
training for this fight 100 pushups 100
sit-ups and 100 squats and while that
training regime might not sound like a
lot which is kind of the joke guys
Saitama seems to possess a seemingly
limitless amount of physical strength
unlike vibranium the mass of Saitama is
a fairly standard 70 kilograms so when
it comes to kinetic energy it's not his
weight that's doing the damage it's his
speed you see all those squats and 10k
runs over the last three years have
given him a velocity that is off the
charts
when Saitama fights the alien invader
Lord Boros he gets knocked to the moon
this is no big deal because Saitama
easily jumps from the moon right back to
earth in less than 19 seconds sadistic
from the earth to the moon is on average
two hundred and thirty eight thousand
six hundred and six miles or 384,000
kilometers which means to travel from
the moon to the earth in 19 seconds or
less saitama's average velocity per
second would have had to have been
twenty million two hundred ten thousand
five hundred meters per second or twelve
million five hundred fifty-eight
thousand two hundred and twenty-two
miles per second that is sixty seven
times the speed of light which means
that when it comes to kinetic energy
Saitama is exerting at least one-half
times seventy kilograms times twenty
million two hundred ten thousand five
hundred squared
142 quadrillion 962 trillion five
hundred eight billion 587 million five
hundred thousand joules of kinetic
energy or about a third of what
vibranium withstood when hit with Thor's
hammer so at the outset it would seem
that vibranium actually Trump's one
punch man it's about three times
stronger than the fastest we see him go
in the anime but it's important to
remember that Saitama is lazy he almost
never uses his full strength in battle
and even though the moon jump is the
fastest that we see a move it's not his
greatest feat of strength for that we
need to examine when he punches through
a planet killing meteor on its way to
earth in Episode 7 we see Saitama stop a
meteor that's described as a level nine
on the Torino scale now that might seem
like it's something that's just made up
for the anime but it's not the Torino
scale is a real method of categorizing
the impact hazard of space objects based
on one their probability of hitting
Earth and two the kinetic energy and
diameter of the asteroid and it gives me
great happiness to report that currently
there are no space objects rated non
zero on the Torino scale it would appear
that are at the safe
but a level 9 meteor is serious business
to give you some context a level 10 is
like the impact that killed off the
dinosaurs and sent earth and ten I see
level nine impacts which do severe
regional damage happen once every ten
thousand a hundred thousand years and
knowing it's a level nine tells us that
the diameter of this asteroid is between
100 meters and one kilometer so to
approximate the mass of this animées
killer asteroid I compared it to 101 955
Bennu an actual planet killing asteroid
floating around in space right now that
fits right into the size range as such
we can say that one punch man's asteroid
has a rough mass of 78 billion kilograms
or 171 billion 960 million five hundred
sixty-four thousand five hundred four
pounds the weight of ten thousand Eiffel
Towers meteors tend to enter Earth's
atmosphere at speeds between 20 and 72
kilometers second so if saitama's
asteroid is traveling at the max speed
of 72 kilometers a second this would
mean that the kinetic energy needed to
at the very least stop this asteroid is
when hampton 202 quintillion one hundred
and seventy-six quadrillion joules that
is four hundred and seventy three times
what we calculated for vibranium which
means that in the battle between Saitama
and vibranium what punch man surges
ahead something that he would be well he
wouldn't really care about all that much
and remember all of this is Saitama
without even breaking a sweat vibranium
on the other hand has shown some cracks
in its literal armor in Avengers age of
Ultron Thor wasn't the only one having
strange visions it's easy to forget Tony
Stark's hallucination where he saw
Captain America's shield broken and all
the Avengers dead amongst the rubble and
well yeah that was just a mind trick
brought about by the Scarlet Witch it
could be a sign of things to come in
Avengers 4 I mean in the comics a number
of people both good and bad have shown
themselves able to destroy Captain
America shield including the man that's
currently on everyone's mind
Thanos in the comics infinity Wars based
on after that infamous snap Earth's
surviving heroes launched a final
desperate attack against mad
thanos still equipped with all six
Infinity stones it doesn't go that well
for them in fact pretty much everyone
dies in a last-ditch effort Captain
America The Last Man Standing battles
Thanos head-on but with one swift punch
Thanos shatters caps shield and that is
how we're able to test the upper limits
of vibranium I know you might be asking
how we could possibly calculate the
energy output of all six Infinity stones
but the thing is we don't have to at the
beginning of this battle in the comics
in an effort to impress mistress death
Thanos
turns off all the other powers except
for the Power Stone even though
throughout the battle he's still doing
reality bending tricks but whatever so
we know that Thanos is punch infused
with the power stone is one of the few
forces able to break through the limits
of vibranium that still leaves us with
the challenge of solving its potential
energy but infinity war gives us exactly
the information that we need
during the climactic battle against
Thanos on Titan we see him use the power
stone to destroy one of the planets
moons and then rain the shards back down
onto Titan's surface fragmenting a moon
like that is certainly powerful but
notice that it doesn't blow up the moon
in one go but rather it has to dismantle
it in one continuous wave across the
planets all of that tells us is that the
energy required to blow up the moon is
ultimately greater than what the
gauntlet can deliver in one punch
because it has to dismantle the moon in
parts rather than travel all at one time
from there believe it or not it's
actually relatively simple to calculate
the energy needed to blow apart a planet
or moon basically all you need to do is
have enough energy to overcome the
gravitational binding energy that's
pulling all that matter into the shape
of the moon it could probably go more
in-depth into that in a future episode
anyway the gravitational binding energy
of a uniform sphere is equal to 3 GM
squared over 5r where G is the
gravitational constant M is the mass of
the sphere and R is its radius so I'm
just gonna use our moon as a stand-in
for the one that Thanos destroys here to
get about 2.0 seven times 10 to the 29th
joules of energy that is 1 billion times
what Saitama had to deliver in order to
destroy that asteroid and that's
honestly where the battle sits right now
do I think one punch man should win this
matchup yeah absolutely the fact that we
haven't seen Saitama break a sweat doing
any of these
extreme feats tells me that he could
punch a moon and very easily destroy it
in one punch however based purely on the
feats of strength that we've seen in
both franchises vibranium has shown
itself able to handle kinetic energy
input far beyond what we've seen Saitama
deliver so is that it vibranium wins at
least until one punch man season two
sometime in 2019 well that white spit
one last twist based on the first law of
thermodynamics energy cannot be created
or destroyed it has to be released
somehow vibranium like we discussed
typically stores and releases the energy
in a controlled way it's one of black
panther's most useful skills however as
we saw when y'all near hit Captain
America's shield vibranium can indeed
withstand all that energy but it can't
quite absorb all that energy resulting
in a shockwave that flattened the forest
a hundred feet in either direction so
imagine what happens if Saitama punches
the vibranium shield with the same force
he used on that meteor or a force equal
to Thanos destroying the mood the
vibranium would be unable to store all
of that energy releasing an even greater
shockwave on the low-end saitama's punch
is almost 474 times more powerful than
the owners the damage would be
unspeakable everything and anyone within
nine miles of that impact would be
totally decimated thus in a battle
between Saitama and vibranium the
ultimate loser would be us but hey
that's just a theory
a film theory and hey if you enjoyed
this episode and haven't seen one punch
man well check it out it's available on
Netflix and Verve right now and while
you're checking out stuff on the
Internet check out my friends over on
wisecrack they helped us by
collaborating on the research for this
episode and they're just awesome guys
they have their main channel wisecrack
which if you've watched this channel for
a while you've heard me mentioned before
but they also have a dedicated new
channel to film analysis called
earthling cinema i watch a lot of film
analysis videos and these are always way
more fun than your average directorial
review or pointy Tweety film school
breakdown those have their place
certainly and I totally binge-watched
those but earthling cinema analyzes
movies from the perspective of an
iliyan who shows up after humans have
gone extinct no joke it's very
outsider's perspective on what makes
movies great and they just posted a new
episode about spider-man homecoming
which was pretty awesome as a movie the
episode talks about everything from how
spider-man homecoming relates to the
tropes of classic 80s movies all the way
to it's parallels with Birdman all
through the perspective of an alien with
incredible eyebrows you should
definitely give this new channel a shot
by clicking the box on the right or the
link in the description and leaving a
comment letting him know that the
theorists were here something that'll
stand out something that reflects the
fact that you know what I'm just gosh
darn hungry as I write this episode
Turkey go to their channel and comment
turkey why are they commenting Turkey
and we'll all know the secret and we'll
just laugh to ourselves that our little
insider Joe so that's it one punch the
link you see on screen and comment on
the video Turkey it'll be our confusing
little secret now if you'll excuse me I
need to go make myself a sandwich and
catch up on another anime that's
currently running what could it be